[Music]
look at that Jaylen Rose Chris Weber
Jimmy and Ray with jwan coaches a fat
five oh man what a great picture see
Jimmy you should have went to Michigan
you would have been a part of the fat
five and they still be talking about you
today they they still talking about
don't worry about it may not always be
good but they heard but but that's the
crew right there I'm fortunate because
one Jimmy King I I still got issues with
him by losing in the elite a though you
had a yeah but
listen to be able to play with Chris and
Jan at different parts of my career
Jimmy King was a free agent that came
and played in Dallas and then of course
Ray doing the outstanding job Jackson
coaching a but also high school and to
have them supported beautiful know that
time when they were playing there was
never anything like that I mean the
black socks the baggy shorts the
Swagger